Considering how much is packed into every
episode of Game of Thrones, it might come
as a surprise that there are plenty of scenes
filmed for the show that never make it to
air.
Luckily, HBO has included many of these deleted
scenes as bonus features for their home releases.
And some of these scenes provide important
character details, and even hints at future
events.
Here's a look at the most important deleted
scenes from Game of Thrones.
Loras and Margaery - Season 2
In this deleted scene from season two, Loras
and Margaery comfort each other following
the murder of Renly Baratheon at the hands
of Stannis Baratheon and Melisandre's shadow
assassin.
Loras is clearly more grief-stricken than
his sister, which makes sense, given Renly
was his true love.
More importantly, viewers get an early glimpse
into Margaery's always scheming mind, as she
carefully steers Loras away from grief and
towards a more pragmatic future supporting
her next political move.
"He was a good man, he was a kind sweet man.
But he is gone now, he doesn't need you anymore.
I need you, our family needs you."
Doreah and Irri - Season 2
During the second season of Game of Thrones,
Daenerys learned an important lesson in trust
when her handmaiden Doreah betrayed her, murdering
the Khaleesi's confidant Irri in the process.
Fans didn't actually see any of that happen,
but the sequence was actually filmed before
being cut later.
In an interview after her departure from Game
of Thrones, actress Amrita Acharia, who played
Irri, revealed that that she was trying so
hard to make the strangulation scene realistic
that she actually suffered real injuries to
her neck while filming.
"I had massive bruises on my neck the next
day.
I was proud.
Battle scars.
Death scenes are fun."
Sansa, The Hound, and Tyrion - Season 2
Sandor Clegane has had one of the most dramatic
character arcs of anyone on the show, as the
Hound has slowly embraced his humanity.
That journey began with his relationship with
the imprisoned Sansa in season two.
But it was a rocky beginning, as this deleted
scene shows.
"Would you sing a song for me little bird.
A song about knights and fair maidens.
Come on sing."
"You won't hurt me"
The scene ends with Tyrion intervening on
behalf of his future wife, giving this brief
deleted sequence yet another layer of foreshadowing.
Pycelle and Tywin - Season 3
Although the audience suspects that Pycelle
is playing his own long game, the other residents
of King's Landing never quite seem to realize
the grand Maester isn't nearly as feeble as
he pretends to be.
But in this deleted scene, we discover that
Tywin has known all along.
More shockingly, Pycelle reveals that it was
his treachery that allowed the Lannisters
to conquer the Seven Kingdoms in the first
place.
"Since the time I convinced the mad king to
open his gates to you, I have served the interests
of the house of Lannister, unfailingly."
Given how much goes on in this short scene,
it's a bit surprising they left it on the
cutting room floor.
Bronn and Shae - Season 4
After Tyrion ends his relationship with Shae
in season four, he sends her away to Pentos
where he hopes she will be safe.
Later, she shockingly resurfaces to testify
against him at his trial.
Why?
Well, the seeds for that were actually planted
in a deleted scene where Tyrion's buddy Bronn
delivers the bad news, along with a speech
about how rich people are all total jerks.
You can almost see Shae's love twisting to
spite as he talks.
"These people, even the good ones.
They use us as they please and when we are
no longer any use they spit us out and find
someones else they like."
Good job, Bronn!
Grey Worm and Missandei - Season 5
In this deleted sequence from season five,
we get to see an extended version of a scene
between Missandei and Grey Worm after the
Unsullied named White Rat was killed in a
Meereen brothel.
We get to see a hint of the beginning of the
romance between Grey Worm and Missandei, as
she tells him that she is afraid what might
happen to him if the Sons of the Harpy attack.
"You will be careful."
"Careful."
"You will protect yourself."
"I protect Daenerys Stormborn."
Of course, shortly after this, Grey Worm was
nearly killed, only surviving thanks to the
sacrifice of Ser Barristan.
Next time, listen to your girlfriend!
Arya and the Mummers - Season 6
In several parts of season six, Arya works
with the troupe of mummers in Braavos as they
perform their satire of Westerosi current
events, The Bloody Hand.
But not everyone in the audience enjoys the
performances as much as Arya, as shown in
this deleted scene.
"Violence and profanity, how original."
"Why don't you just leave then."
If you're familiar with the controversy surrounding
the show after the events following Sansa's
wedding to Ramsay Snow in season five, it's
not hard to recognize this deleted scene as
a subtle dig at viewers who complain about
the show but continue to tune in anyway.
"I'm going on a wild boar hunt."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!